hello everybody hope they are good it's
been a while it was the weekend and
yesterday was bank holiday in many
European countries and also in the US so
I didn't trade into the Asian session
I'm gonna tell you now in a minute what
I think that it's going on
but I think it's important to talk first
about what is happening behind the chart
the dead seating deal so on Saturday
they announced some kind of agreement
between By Dana McCarthy for Rising the
debt ceiling okay so this seems to be
some kind of deal that was over the
weekend so Bitcoin could react to it I
need it okay
um the stock market and the dollar Index
couldn't so let's see what happens today
I posted on Twitter with the Sunday
update my thoughts about this and it was
some kind of reverse psychology or sell
the news event so it happens well nobody
expects kind of because well everybody
thinks is obviously if they rise the
debt ceiling
um the printing machine goes and the
dollar Index goes up right so I was
expecting the opposite okay let's see
what the dollar Index does today
but I'm expecting the dollar Index to do
the opposite okay the market is going to
be able to absorb you know those news
released over the weekend today so today
it should be quite a volatile day or at
least that's what I'm expecting I'm
expecting another index to go down okay
that was this projection for Bitcoin
because you know I make projections well
they are based on price and also in
timing so it's not a coincidence that
you know I'm making an arrow up today
okay so yes we could say that today I
would expect the dollar Index to go down
and maybe Bitcoin can go up I'm gonna
tell you why okay this was the
projection from the Sunday update uh you
can see it's a bit uh off because uh
price went a bit lower than I thought
okay but you can see that it's again
recovered in that soon and I'm gonna
show you why I think that this can
happen okay first of all this target why
this target okay this is why train line
it's from the end of March okay you can
see that this was quite a resistance
Zone then here I try to test it as
support then tested the resistance with
this week
um again here trying to say the support
resistance support so you can see it's
quite important trend line that's why
I'm expecting the price could come back
to this Zone okay now if we focus again
on Lower time frame well you're gonna be
able to see still in the forward time
frame that we have a week here okay
they're gonna be able to see it this
week here
so we are expecting a recovery of these
zones here right that will be the 50 of
the week
and
on the top yellow line that will be the
100 of the book okay so at least we're
expecting that they feel the 50 of the
week now could we see
Adam from here
okay what I mean is that could we see
a name
pattern here okay at least recovering
the 50 of the week okay so it could be
here or they might just look over the
whole week okay let's do the 50 of the
week and then dump
yes why not
my point is that I think the price is
not finished here I think that at least
they have to recover the 50 of the week
and of course there might be some kind
of you know uh push up retrace and then
another push up okay and that could be
to this target so yesterday uh during
the Asian session I was able to get into
a long I saw the week to the upside so I
knew that price you know it's probably
gonna try to come to this one again and
then I saw this works to the downside
here I saw another week here with an
imbalance because this week is quite a
long week so then I placed my order
at the 50 percent of the week I think it
was exactly here 27 609 got failed you
can see and then price is now going up
so the moment I'm fine okay price is 400
up at the moment I'm safe I'm planning
to take profit of most my position here
okay at the 50 of the week that's the
plan I have today I don't know if any of
you saw the same plan yesterday uh if
you did please let me know in the
comments it's not Financial advice I'm
only sharing with you my analysis um
what I'm doing but basically uh if price
prompts here today this is what I'm
gonna close most of my position okay and
when I say most of my position I'm in 75
of the position because first I'm a bit
scared that we might see a name
pattern here okay second because if you
notice uh Asia really you know they they
held really so if you notice that's the
price difference it was a price
difference of
it's almost nothing okay so we could say
that Asia held and now London seems to
be pumping okay as you can see here
so
why not I mean uh you have to be careful
okay because if you start to see
you know another poem and we feel the 50
of the week then maybe New York
reverses this Zone okay so I don't want
to go back to my entry point okay that's
when I'm gonna be playing attention to
the charts today you know the moment
that I see some kind of uh for example
in this one here weeks weeks weeks but
price cannot break this one then I'm
closing my position here
okay but my Target today Remains the 50
of the week until I see something
different okay
um then from here I'm not saying to take
a sure that's quite risky to be honest
because price can you know continue
going higher I hit this target okay so
you have to be very careful uh after in
the Sunday update
I'm not planning
to have a limit order here because
that's not how Traders trade
um in my opinion a good Trader reacts to
price
okay and that means that I want to see
what price does in this Zone if we come
here okay now what I see for example if
we can see some kind of deviation and
then we go lower okay then at this point
I'm opening shorts here okay if we see
some kind of deviation uh but if I place
a short limit order here then maybe
price just continue going higher for
example to 29 29 and a half so that's
what you have to be careful guys
if you're a swing Trader then yes you
can just play limit orders and chill
okay
because you are playing for a longer
term but you know in the case of a day
trader you have to react to price if we
look for a bit of context uh we could
say that we've been in this range for
quite some time uh that's exactly around
a bit more than three weeks okay so you
have your low then it got retested of
course you have a week that you go
filled here okay and remember that when
we were in this Zone I was telling you
guys that this week needs to get failed
so if you are in long you are not safe
because price is eventually gonna come
lower
to fill this week okay quite similar to
what we're saying now okay we have a
week
and I think that price
before it comes low it has to fill this
week first that's that's my theory okay
that's what I'm thinking now uh the
question is uh well first a bit more of
context okay on Friday's video we were
saying that you know where we had this
train line here the I use them for
liquidity purposes because it's telling
me that
um you know price poems then the retail
Trader is gonna find here some kind of
trend line okay they're gonna Place
their lungs in this Zone and the rest
stop losses below all the time so you
can see that this train and play out
quite frequent okay
and usually I was telling you that what
I see is some kind of a very aggressive
move
okay
before breaking below this train line
because after this aggressive move
the little traditional feel bullish and
it's gonna Place more long Sia quite
heavily because they don't want to miss
out on the next move to the upside okay
that's what I think that why not this
could be a deviation out of the range
okay uh imagine I've seen these
deviation so I'm going to show you in an
example okay but why not this could be
alleviation here okay out of the range I
will come again Lower okay because in
this one here
that is called of liquidity in the 25
400 zone or 25 250. okay remember the
old videos so why not we could see some
kind of M pattern here
okay
and then
get back into the range break below the
trail line and go again to this Lucia or
even go lower okay and break below
that's an option okay that's what I
think that this level here is very
important okay if price goes up
support
then you know we're gonna go higher
um this idea of deviation is invalidated
you know we've broke out of the range
it's great all right but do you still
have the chance of
an M pattern here
okay
there
or
that will take you back into the inside
range or you could even see some kind of
deviation here okay to at least test
this level here again that's around uh
27 500 to remain a bit lower here
to fill the CME Gap okay so that's
pretty much what I think uh
in the very short term I think I want to
have to fill this week first then from
here I want to see what price does if
they print an information or if they
come to this level here let's see what
they do here we could see a sharp
rejection a deviation or tester support
and go high okay and these are the
scenarios that you have to know and you
have to know how to execute this and how
to react to price
okay so that's pretty much what I think
about Bitcoin at the moment before I
finish the video I want to tell you guys
that tonight at 10 pm UTC time I'm
announcing the 10 winners of the trading
course giveaway these 10 winners are
gonna be able to do the trading course
for free in July you guys know that it's
full in July 2 so it's a good
opportunity also the chances of winning
are quite higher just check and it's one
out of three chances for winning so you
know it's quite high so 30 percent
chances of winning pretty much so I
invite you to participate you can
participate until 30 minutes before I
announce the winners so that's until 9
30 PM UTC time today uh you only need to
sign up with a link in the description
and deposit at least a hundred dollars
there are also more benefits 15 trading
fees discount in all your trades for
life also if you deposit between 200 or
1000 dollars you get 10 payback that
means that for example if you deposit
say 500 you get fifty dollars for free
of course if you deposit more you can
you get more bonuses that's pretty much
everything I want to say guys thank you
so much for watching the video and I'll
see you soon